album of the uh
it wasn't the actual devil no they were
just dressed as the devil mom Ben
Affleck goes viral for looking super
serious at the 2023 Grammys couldn't be
that bad Ben accompanied his wife
Jennifer Lopez to the award show Sunday
night where they were seated front row
center now we all know what happens when
you're sitting in the front row you end
up on camera
a lot and that's just what happened to
Ben and Jen
while Jen appeared to be having a blast
the actor started trending on Twitter
with fans claiming he looked majorly
bored during music's biggest night one
person writing however bad of a day
you're having I promise you're not as
miserable as Ben Affleck at the Grammys
right now another tweeting Ben Affleck
is every husband dragged to a work thing
by his wife
[Music]
during the Epic back to Motown medley
Jen was up on her feet dancing while Ben
stood next to her stone-faced and when
Grammy host Trevor Noah did a skit
talking to his mom on the phone while
sitting next to the couple at their
table Jen appeared to give Ben a playful
nudge when she realized they were on
camera yeah I gotta go I gotta go all
right I got no no Mom no Mom it wasn't
the actual devil the couple didn't walk
the red carpet together and Jen didn't
perform but she did present the first
award of the evening best pop vocal
album which went to Harry Styles
Harry's house Harry stop
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah so Jen's duties for the night
appeared to be done within the first 15
minutes of the broadcast but we don't
blame her for staying to watch all the
amazing performances just gonna try to
enjoy every minute stay present and Ben
he's been letting Jen shine at events
while supporting her from the background
I was super happy last month she worked
the red carpet at her shotgun wedding
Premiere solo while Ben joined her
inside of course they haven't shied away
from flaunting their love on the red
carpet in the past now Jen is set to
release her ninth studio album this is
me now the follow-up to 2002's this is
me then which famously featured a track
dedicated to her then fiance titled dear
Ben
of you
you're perfect a manifestation of my
dreams
the new album will include a song titled
dear Ben part 2 which documents the
second act of their love story the same
way this is me then captured a moment in
time a very special moment in time
this album
also did the same thing captured a very
special moment in time so this is me now
so something tells us he'll be smiling a
whole lot more at the Grammys next year
[Music]
thank you